[Música]
después segura que el 99% de la
audiencia no entendía lo que estaba
comunicando les
el número de personas
y aprender
aprenden eso es sólo el 10%
esta es una forma de comunicación muy
importante
puede mejorar la vida de personas cuando
yo
un estudio que hizo la asociación de
sordos
en el año 2015
en honduras hay alrededor de 32
sordos
la mayoría d
no ha logrado
y tener una educación
lengua de señas
para mí la vida
un ácido paso
aparte de nacer mujer sois
y he tratado
hay que comunicarme con mis padres y
amigos
sin tener una educación correcta
es cuando estando ya adulta logré
terminar la escuela y aprender lengua de
señas
para mí el eso se convierte en vivir
y en la forma en cómo ha podido aportar
mi grano de arena para tener una mejor
inclusión
por eso cuando se me brindó una
oportunidad empecé a enseñar
lengua de signos
de la municipalidad es un faro sur
la lengua de señas
es hondureño
y es la lengua natural de las personas
sordas
varía en algunos países del mundo
se basta se basa en movimientos
corporales
y gestos faciales como movimientos de
ojos y boca
se usan las manos
es aprendido por las personas
también
por las personas oyentes que quieran
aprenderlo
para entender lo que las personas sordas
comunicamos a través de eso
no es usado mucho el deletreo cabe
mencionar que hay algunas señas para
cada palabra
hoy quiero hacerles una pregunta
uno de ustedes ha conocido alguna
persona sorda
podemos aprender hoy a decir eso en
lengua de señas
bien
y ahora mucho gusto
y aplausos
porque hacemos esto este movimiento con
algunos porque las personas sordas no
podemos escuchar sus aplausos cuando
usamos este movimiento así podemos
sentir la felicidad para todos
invito a todos a abrir sus mentes y sus
corazones
para que aprendan este maravilloso arte
del eso
la discapacidad es una
que debemos aprovechar
para tener
y demostrar
una verdadera incluso
gracias